let's go back to 1989 for a second you
remember the Menendez brothers those
guys they they famously murdered their
parents right here in Los Angeles
well someone someone recently discovered
an old NBA trading card and in the
background of the card you can see the
Menendez brothers sitting courtside this
is real check it out this is a Mark
Jackson card right and then you go for
the next you push into the background
those are the real Menendez brothers yes
this photo was taken a couple of days
after the Menendez brothers murdered
their parents just a couple of days and
they went to a basketball game Wow they
took a picture at the basketball game
and that became the NBA card Wow
it's really weird and I thought people
have been talking about it talk about
what a freaking coincidence it is that
they're in the background and then I
looked into it it turns out this is not
the only time murderers have been
spotted in the background of
professional sports trading cards no
it's not I did the research I did I
don't know why you're giggling cuz I
think this is a serious matter
this is Oakland A's slugger Jose Canseco
is baseball card and if you zoom in in
the background there's Charles Manson in
the dog oh yeah that's right Andy he's
sitting in the dugout they let him hang
out Wow and here's Ken griffeys baseball
card and if you zoom in in the
background it's the cloud
from it and this is the weirdest one of
all finally here's Hall of Fame running
back Oh J Simpson's card if you zoom in
there in the background convicted
criminal offenses kind of time-warp
there